GRACE: Dr. Lorraine Murphy
is an associate professor
of English at Hillsdale
College, where she has
taught for the past 10 years.
A recipient of the Emily
Daugherty Award for Teaching
Excellence, she teaches courses
in realism, the 18th century
novel, and Jane Austen.
She serves as faculty advisor to
the Cravats and Blue Stockings
Regency Appreciation Club and as
secretary for the Phi Kappa Phi
Honor Society.
She taught a Hillsdale College
online course titled "The Young
Jane Austen, Northanger
Abbey," which
is available at
online.Hillsdale.edu.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Murphy.
[APPLAUSE]
LORRAINE MURPHY:
Thank you, Grace.
And I'd also like to thank
Doug Jeffrey and Matt
Bell for inviting me to speak
and all of you for being here
to listen.
That her novels have been so
repeatedly and successfully
adapted to film tells us
something of Austen's skill
in scripting plot and character.
But one thing a film cannot
give you is the voice
of the narrator.
I'd like to open tonight
with a passage from Emma
that I believe reveals something
essential about Austen's
particular genius.
Emma, in this passage, has
accompanied her protege Harriet
to the general
store in Highbury.
"Harriet, tempted by everything
and swayed by half a word,
was always very
long at a purchase.
And while she was still
hanging over muslins
and changing her mind, Emma
went to the door for amusement.
Much could not be hoped from
the traffic of even the busiest
part of Highbury--
Mr. Perry walking hastily by,
Mr. William Cox letting himself
in at the office door,
Mr. Cole's carriage horses
returning from exercise,
or a stray letter boy
on an obstinate mule were
the liveliest objects
she could presume to expect.
And when her eyes fell
only on the butcher
with his tray, a tidy old
woman traveling homewards
from shop with her full
basket, two curs quarreling
over a dirty bone, and
a string of dawdling
children around the baker's
little bow window eyeing
the gingerbread, she knew
she had no reason to complain
and was amused enough,
quite enough still
to stand at the door.
A mind lively and at ease
can do with seeing nothing
and can see nothing
that does not answer."
This, I suggest, is the
secret to Austen's art.
Gratefully secure in a mundane
setting where others might
see nothing of
interest, Jane Austen
could do with seeing nothing.
Her lively mind could
discern and articulate
the meaning in a series
of commonplace actions
that would not answer to
a more callous observer.
By addressing her attention to
an ordinary scene such as this,
Austen gives it a voice.
The most everyday materials
are rendered eloquent
by her precise and
affectionate language.
It's my privilege this evening
to talk about Austen's life
with the aim of understanding
how it nurtured her talent.
And my thesis is this--
that her life and
work were fueled
by a passionate or, in the
words of GK Chesterton,
an "exuberant interest
in the ordinary."
Jane Austen's
natural exuberance is
enriched over the
course of her life
by a network of
love and friendship
that brings her into
contact with every variety
of anticipation, disappointment,
uncertainty, loss, hope,
laughter, and joy we can know.
Perhaps her natural reserve
with strangers, as well as
the unpredictable nature
of some relationships,
encouraged that close
scrutiny of the minutia
of our social behavior that
is a hallmark of her fiction
and a large part of what
makes it so filmable.
Her exuberant spirit is somewhat
chastened by a prolonged period
of hardship and the awareness
of her dependent position
in society.
Yet the sense of
joyful possibility
remains from first to
last ever expressed
in her work with a
Mozartian fluency
in the resources of
the English language.
She is unfailingly precise,
and funny, and real.
She was born-- excuse me--
December 16, 1775, seventh of
her parents' eight children.
The Austens were not
financially prosperous.
But they were hardworking,
energetic, and busy.
And theirs was a home where the
written word was celebrated.
Jane's father, the
Reverend George Austen,
served as rector of the
Church of St. Nicholas,
seen here, in the small
village of Steventon, County
of Hampshire,
southwest of London.
Here you see the church
door framed by carvings not
of saints or angels but of
a man's face and a woman's.
Reverend Austen farmed
in his spare time,
ran a boys boarding school
out of their crowded home,
seen here, and collected a
library of some 500 volumes
that Jane was free to
borrow from as she pleased.
His wife Cassandra, in
addition to her duties
as mother, school mistress,
head gardener, and manager
of the dairy and
poultry yards, still
found time to write witty
poems for special occasions.
And Jane's older
brothers published
a periodical and
supervised the staging of
plays when family and friends
gathered at their parsonage
for the holidays.
The children would
have no inheritance
to speak of from their parents.
Indeed, Reverend
Austen and his wife
spent several years
digging their way out
of debt on a very small income.
Their eldest son James
took a degree at Oxford
and became a clergyman,
inheriting his father's post
at Steventon when he retired.
The next son, George, suffered
an unspecified disability,
perhaps a seizure disorder
or perhaps cerebral palsy.
But he lived a long
and otherwise healthy
life in the care of a family
in a neighboring village.
The third brother, Edward,
was adopted at the age of 12
by distant relations who were
very wealthy and childless.
He remained close with
his parents and siblings
and came to play a pivotal
role in Jane's life.
But financially and
socially, his adoption
removed him to another sphere.
Henry was the most gregarious
Austen and followed
several professions, including
army officer, banker,
and clergyman in the course
of his interesting life.
Francis and Charles,
the two youngest boys,
pursued careers in
the navy, Francis
rising to the rank of admiral.
Finally, little Cassandra
was like a second mother
to her younger sister Jane.
Mrs. Austen remarked,
"if Cassandra's head
had been going to
be cut off, Jane
would have hers cut off too."
Jane's formal schooling was
brief and perhaps blessedly so
as girls' schools could be a
breeding ground for infections
that were too often fatal.
She made a narrow escape
from a serious illness
after being sent away to
school at the age of seven.
Returned safely home,
she mastered needlework,
which was a vital part
of her contribution
to the household economy,
and enjoyed piano.
Cassandra studied drawing.
Her father must have encouraged
Jane to enjoy his library.
And her brothers must have
brought new publications home
on a regular basis for by the
time she began writing fiction
at 12 or 13, she was
familiar with the classics
of the earlier 18th century,
the essays of Samuel Johnson
and the novels of
Samuel Richardson,
as well as more contemporary
novels by Charlotte
Lennox, Fanny Burney, Maria
Edgeworth, and Ann Radcliffe.
Three leatherbound
notebooks were
her first prized possessions.
The second is inscribed
"a gift from my father."
And the third is inscribed in
the hand of Reverend Austen
himself, who praises
his daughter's stories
as "effusions of fancy by a very
young lady consisting of tales
in a style entirely new."
One of the longer stories
in the second notebook
is dated June 1790,
when Jane was 14.
Her first notebook was
by then already full.
Her practice was to
draft on scrap paper
and then transcribe her
stories into the notebooks
when she considered them ready,
so to speak, for publication.
Individual stories were
dedicated to various friends
and family members.
And the notebooks were passed
around in the Austen circle
in the manner of
published books.
It sounds very
serious, and it is.
But the stories themselves
are full of hilarity.
Young Jane delights in satire.
And in particular,
she enjoys sending up
the emotional excess
that was characteristic
of popular fiction at the time.
In a story in the
epistolary style composed
as a series of letters
that Jane wrote at 14,
she gives us the following with
her protagonist Laura writing
to a younger woman, Marianne.
"Convinced as you must be from
what I have already told you
concerning Augustus and Sophia,
that there never were a happier
couple, I need not,
I imagine, inform you
that their union had been
contrary to the inclinations
of their cruel and mercenary
parents, who had vainly
endeavored, with
obstinate perseverance,
to force them into a
marriage with those
whom they had ever abhorred.
But with an heroic fortitude
worthy to be related
and admired, they had
both constantly refused
to submit to such
despotic power.
After having so nobly
disentangled themselves
from the shackles of
parental authority
by a clandestine marriage,
they were determined never
to forfeit the good opinion
they had gained in the world
in so doing by accepting any
proposals of reconciliation
that might be offered
them by their fathers.
To this farther trial of
their noble independence,
however, they were
never exposed."
[LAUGHTER]
She further displays
her mastery of satire
in The History of England
by a Partial, Prejudiced
and Ignorant
Historian, in which she
imitates the dry narration
of Gibbon and Goldsmith
and includes a running
joke on her fidelity
to Mary, Queen of Scots.
Here she gives us the reign of
Edward VI, son of Henry VIII.
"As this prince was
only nine years old
at the time of his
father's death,
he was considered by many
people as too young to govern.
And the late king,
happening to be
of the same opinion,
his mother's brother,
the Duke of Somerset, was
chosen protector of the realm
during his minority.
The duke was beheaded, of
which he might with reason have
been proud, had
he known that such
was the death of Mary,
Queen of Scotland,
but as it was impossible that
he should be conscious of what
had never happened,
it does not appear
that he felt
particularly delighted
with the manner of it."
[LAUGHTER]
The use of humor to probe the
darker side of human behavior
from a safe distance is
perfected in a complete novella
Austen wrote, probably in
1794, when she would have been
18 years old titled Lady Susan.
It's in the epistolary
form and features
a smart, manipulative,
almost amoral protagonist,
a widow and mother who uses
charm and a thorough mastery
of social conventions
to get on in the world,
cheerfully disrupting
and privately
laughing at the dull but
well-meaning people who
come in her way.
This is the story what Stillman
adopted as Love and Friendship,
the film we're
screening tomorrow.
And I can assure you that it's
something very delightful.
The story's power derives from
the charisma of Lady Susan
herself but also from the
exposure of mannered behavior
as a resource that,
while ostensibly designed
to convey respect
and deference, can
be deployed for completely
self-serving ends.
And this, I think,
is an insight that
propels Jane Austen into the
world of her mature fiction.
The very next year,
1795, she began
to draft the novel that
would many years later become
her first published work,
Sense and Sensibility.
Then titled Elinor
and Marianne, it's
a study, among other
things, of the value
of suppressing emotion out
of consideration for others.
Elinor Dashwood is the
opposite of Lady Susan
in every respect but one, that
her demeanor does not reflect
her true thoughts and feelings.
When we step into society,
we step into a role,
as Elinor knows too well.
And Marianne, who can be
nothing but natural and sincere,
suffers greatly in
London, where Willoughby
is free to politely rebuff her.
In Ang Lee's film, we
rejoice that Colonel Brandon
will protect Marianne from that
knowledge of the world that
might render her more
mature but less unspoilt.
It's a story of two
sisters in love.
And for a brief time, Jane and
Cassandra knew that happiness.
In 1795, Cassandra
had been engaged
to Tom Fowle, a young clergyman
with very little income,
for three years.
That autumn, Tom agreed
to sail to the West Indies
as chaplain for a regiment
of the British militia.
Upon his return,
they would marry.
Cassandra spent that
Christmas holiday
with the Fowle family in
Berkshire to see Tom off.
And the visit is the occasion
for our first surviving letter
from Jane to her sister,
dated January 1796,
when Jane was just 20.
With the satiric humor
that hardly disguises
a sense of joyful
anticipation, Jane
refers to a young
man named Tom Lefroy,
an Irish cousin of
neighbors with whom
the Austens were friendly.
He's visiting Hampshire
on his way to London.
And Jane confesses that she's
danced with him repeatedly,
that Tom is being teased
about his attachment to her,
and that she greatly
enjoys his company.
"I'm almost afraid to tell
you how my Irish friend and I
behaved," she writes.
"Imagine to yourself everything
most profligate and shocking
in the way of dancing and
sitting down together."
[LAUGHTER]
It's appropriate to
pause here and say
a word about Austen's letters.
She wrote them to scores
of friends and relations.
But, in particular, when she
and Cassandra were separated,
Jane wrote copiously and often.
In a stream of
consciousness style,
she records neighborhood news,
visits given and received,
the appearance or dress
of this or that person,
the quality of a meal.
And she often works out
the cutting side of her wit
as if seizing an outlet
for honest thoughts
impossible to
express in company.
In that sense, a picture of
her character drawn exclusively
from her letters would
be woefully incomplete.
It's clear that Cassandra
burned precisely
the more personal missives to
protect her sister's privacy.
Claire Tomalin, whose biography
of Austen I highly recommend,
remarks of this
letter to Cassandra.
"The fact that the manuscript
Elinor and Marianne was lying
completed somewhere in
the house as she wrote
gives this first letter
an added resonance.
It is the only surviving
letter in which Jane is clearly
writing as the heroine of
her own youthful story,
living for herself the short
period of power, excitement,
and adventure that might
come to a young woman
when she was thinking
of choosing a husband.
Just for a brief time, she is
enacting instead of imagining.
We can't help knowing that
her personal story will not
go in the direction she is
imagining in the letter,
that, as it turned out, it
was not Tom Lefroy or anyone
like him who became her
adventure but the manuscript
upstairs, not marriage but art.
And in her art, she made this
short period in a young woman's
life carry such wit and human
understanding as few writers
have managed to cram into solemn
volumes three times the size."
75 years later, Tom Lefroy
told Austen's nephew
that he fell in love with
Jane then with a boyish love.
But he was expected
to study law and work
for his family's advancement.
And he could not afford
to marry a woman who
wouldn't bring him a penny.
He later indeed became
a judge and then
Lord Chief Justice of Ireland,
amply fulfilling his family's
trust and expectation.
So the relations with
whom he was staying
whisked him away and took care
of that he and Jane did not
cross paths on his
subsequent visits.
She never saw him again.
Cassandra's fiancee died
of a fever in Santo Domingo
in the spring of 1797.
And though she was
still in her 20s,
she never considered
another marriage.
Jane, on the other hand, did
entertain that possibility,
but we'll come to
that in its place.
How would Jane Austen have
appeared to a potential suitor?
The descriptions of young
men and women in her novels
are not terribly detailed.
She focuses on height,
the manner of movement,
and the quality of expression
that can be found in the eyes.
We know that Cassandra was
considered the prettier
of the two sisters.
Jane's brother Henry said
that had Jane been any taller,
she would have exceeded
the middle height.
Several relations described
her as either slender or spare.
Her posture was
upright, and her step
was light and firm or
quick and decisive.
Her eyes were bright and her
cheeks were full of color.
Notably, she is the only
one of eight siblings,
excepting her
brother George, who
never had a professional
portrait of any kind taken.
The only image that survives
that was taken from the life
is this sketch with some
watercolor drawn by her sister
Cassandra, seen here, though
Austen's niece Anna, with whom
she was close, later declared
that this portrait was
hideously unlike her Aunt Jane.
[LAUGHTER]
So she remains a
bit of a mystery.
And fittingly, we meet her
in her language rather than
any image.
In the summer of
1796, Reverend Austen
made a decision,
the first of two
that would have momentous
consequences for his daughter
Jane.
Well clear of debt and
with their sons embarked
on their respective
careers, he and his wife
would cease taking boarders
and running their home
as a boy's school.
This meant that the burden of
cooking, serving, and cleaning
was greatly lessened for
the women of the house
and that Jane had
more leisure to write.
That autumn, she began
drafting First Impressions,
the work later renamed
Pride and Prejudice.
Within a year, she had
polished that to satisfaction
and took up Elinor
and Marianne, revising
from the epistolary style
to third person narration.
And I think this effort
shows the sense of a vocation
and something much
more than the desire
to simply write for the
amusement of herself
or her family.
In 1798 and '99, she wrote
the novel later published
as Northanger Abbey,
then titled Susan.
And in November
1797, Jane's father,
possibly without her
knowledge, sent a letter
to one Thomas Cadell,
a publisher in London
whose firm had printed the
works of Gibbon and Johnson.
Reverend Austen
wrote that he had
a manuscript for a
novel in his possession
and would Mr. Cadell
consider bringing it out
at the author's expense.
The publisher opened
the letter, wrote
"declined by return of
post" across the top,
and mailed it back.
The fact that
Austen's father was
one of her most ardent admirers
makes it all the more poignant
that his well-deserved
retirement from the parish
of Steventon brought
Jane's writing
life to a decisive halt. This
second and equally momentous
decision was announced
to Jane and Cassandra
over the Christmas
holidays of 1800.
By January 1801, plans to
move to Bath were underway.
Jane's piano was now sold.
Her father's library
was sold off too.
Her parents intended to enjoy
the crowded social calendar--
theater, dances, card parties--
commonly regarded as one of
the prime attractions of Bath
and to take various
forays to seaside resorts.
Jane and her parents removed
to temporary lodgings
that spring while Cassandra
made a visit with friends
before joining them.
And Jane's letters
from this time
reflect a struggle
with low spirits.
"Another stupid party
last night," she wrote.
"One card table with six people
to look over and talk nonsense
to each other."
Regarding their search for
a home, "when you arrive,
we will at least
have the pleasure
of examining some of these
putrefying houses again.
They are so very desirable
in size and situation
that there is some satisfaction
in spending 10 minutes within."
And the note of dejection
is unmistakable.
"I cannot, anyhow, continue
to find people agreeable."
this from a woman who could
make a cramped setting,
or a trivial card game,
or a disagreeable person
bristle with
interest on the page.
In her writing desk
were manuscripts
for three complete novels,
but her words now dried up.
That Jane was tempted by a
marriage proposal in 1802
may reflect both her unhappiness
in Bath and her sense
that her period of creative
fruitfulness was at an end.
Harris Bigg-Wither was
the younger brother
of three sisters who were
close, lifelong friends
to Jane and Cassandra.
He was five years Jane's junior
when he proposed to her just
shortly before her
27th birthday while she
was visiting for the holidays.
Harris was the only son
and heir to his father's
considerable estates.
And as he would be
wealthy in his own right,
there was no need for
any dowry on her side.
Jane accepted his
proposal, and the family
celebrated the good news.
But by early next morning,
she had packed her bags
and asked to see Harris again.
We can't know what
passed between them,
other than that she
withdrew her acceptance
and made arrangements
to leave immediately.
Did she determine
that she could not
be happy in the absence
of romantic love?
Did she fear the risks
associated with bringing
children into the world?
Was she unable to face the
prospect of giving up her
writing for good?
We can only speculate on the
basis of those of her heroines
who turned down
offers of marriage,
Elizabeth Bennet, who
will not marry Mr. Collins
because, in the absence of
deep respect and affection,
they will not make
one another happy;
Fanny Price, who turns down
Henry Crawford because she
doubts his integrity
of character;
and Anne Elliott,
who refuses Charles
Musgrove because her heart
still belongs to another man.
In January of 1885, the Reverend
Austen died peacefully in Bath.
For four years, Jane had carried
her manuscripts from place
to place, packed in
her writing desk.
As far as we know, she had
attempted only one fragment
of a composition never pursued.
True, in 1803, she
had achieved what
might be called her first
professional success by selling
the manuscript of
Northanger Abbey
to the publisher Richard
Crosby for 10 pounds, something
like $400 in our currency.
But as Crosby never
printed her work,
this was a somewhat discouraging
success as first successes go.
And now the Austen women, Jane,
Cassandra, and their mother,
were effectively homeless.
They must forfeit the annuity
Reverend Austen had earned
as part of his retirement.
They would live on whatever
Jane's brothers together
could provide them
with the interests
that Mrs. Austen
and Cassandra earned
on some small investments.
Jane had none.
They sometimes stayed near
relations in Bath but only
in rented lodgings.
They sometimes stayed
with friends in Hampshire
and sometimes with
Jane's brother Edward
at his large estate
in Kent, seen here.
But they never stayed
any one place very long.
And they were always
visitors or guests.
This continued for
another four years,
making a gap of eight years
in the career of a young woman
who began to write at
12 or 14 and died at 41.
Finally, in 1809,
Edward Austen, owner
of a great deal of land
and property, this estate
and others, realized there
were houses at his disposal
and that his mother and sisters
might like to stay in one.
[LAUGHTER]
They chose a rather
large brick home
situated at a crossroads in
Chawton village in Hampshire.
They had a garden
to work at the back.
Mrs. Austen was a
devoted gardener.
And they spent time
making clothes and giving
reading lessons to
some of the needier
children in the village.
Jane's life was
effectively transformed.
The women agreed that Jane
would prepare the family
breakfast of tea and toast.
She was typically
the first to rise.
But thereafter, the
cooking, gardening,
and general housework
would be overseen
by her sister and mother.
And in moments of
leisure, Jane could write.
She began immediately, took the
manuscripts out of her writing
desk, and set to revision.
Her lively mind, set at ease by
the security of a settled home,
could once again do
with seeing nothing.
And this ordinary nothing,
the nothing special
of a daily routine that had
been so long denied her,
could once again answer
her attentiveness
with the voice of inspiration.
In 1810, she sold
Sense and Sensibility
and saw her first work in
print the following year,
a commercial success.
The achievement must
have been all the sweeter
given how long she had waited.
And from our perspective, it's
made bittersweet by the fact
that Austen would enjoy the
full exercise of her powers
for only five more years.
But as an exuberant
and energetic writer,
she made them count.
With one commercial
success to her name,
her publisher,
Thomas Egerton, was
happy to purchase the copyright
to Pride and Prejudice
in November of 1812.
Jane describes lopping and
cropping her 1797 manuscript
into the form so beloved
by all her admirers.
Elizabeth Bennett
never fails to charm us
with her intelligence,
self-assurance,
and sense of humor.
And Fitzwilliam Darcy
is a man of reserve
whose warm and devoted
nature is gradually revealed.
The drama turns on
that moment when
Elizabeth, overly trusting
of her first impressions,
is forced to revise her
estimation of Wickham,
of Darcy, and most
especially of herself.
But alongside that
plot line runs
another and related one that
is, I think, easy to overlook.
And in fact, our 1940
film version of the novel
elides this.
Though she's
enlightened regarding
Wickham's true history
with the Darcy family,
there are still depths
to Mr. Darcy's character
that Elizabeth has
not yet plumbed,
and so she still faces, as we
all must, a moment of decision,
of faith.
And it is her instinctive,
almost unthinking willingness
in the novel to trust Mr. Darcy
with her sister's humiliating
story that actually allows him
to rescue Lydia and the Bennet
family's reputation.
Jane spent the next
two years drafting
her most ambitious work
yet, Mansfield Park.
It is the work most provocative
of differences among her fans.
And I've not yet seen a film
that I believe does it justice.
Its heroine is Fanny Price,
one of nine siblings born
to overwhelmed and far
from prosperous parents.
But her mother's sister
has married a baronet.
And the Bertram family
offered to adopt Fanny
as a way of helping out.
She grows into womanhood
in outwardly comfortable
circumstances but remains
painfully shy, physically weak,
and of a somewhat secondary
status among the Bertrams.
Edmund, the kindest
of her cousins,
is her only friend apart from
her brother William, with whom
she corresponds devotedly.
These illustrations from
a late Victorian edition
might give you a sense of
Fanny's somewhat passive
demeanor.
The settled way of
life at Mansfield Park
is pleasantly unsettled by the
arrival in their neighborhood
of Henry and Mary Crawford,
a brother and sister
raised in London--
Mary Crawford, something of a
cross between Elizabeth Bennet
and Lady Susan, Henry Crawford
a flirt who may charm the reader
but cannot succeed
in charming Fanny.
He hatches a plan to make
her fall in love with him
and is appropriately punished
by falling in love with her
himself and by surprising
both himself and the reader
with his potential
for transformation.
Cassandra begged
Jane to let Henry
win Fanny's hand in marriage.
But she had other
plans, and Fanny
marries her own secret
love, Cousin Edmund.
Mansfield Park features
searching debates
on the morality of acting,
the value of formal prayer,
and the settled versus
the mobile way of life.
But I think its most
remarkable feature
is that Austen sustains our
interest in a heroine who,
unlike every young woman
she'd previously scripted,
almost never speaks.
I wonder sometimes
if Fanny's silence
in the face of people and
events that swirl around her,
constant reminders
of her dependence,
reflects something of what
Austen herself experienced
during eight years when she
seldom held a pen in her hands.
Mansfield Park was
published in 1814, a year
after Pride and Prejudice.
As if conscious that it
would not be so well liked,
Austen kept a bemused record
of the opinions expressed
by friends and relations.
Her professional success
was increasingly known
in her family circle but was
by no means universal knowledge
among her acquaintance.
Of Mansfield Park, she notes,
"Mr. Egerton, the publisher,
praised it for its morality
and for being so equal
a composition.
No weak parts.
Meanwhile, a Hampshire neighbor
must have unwittingly confessed
that she thought Sense
and Sensibility and Pride
and Prejudice downright
nonsense but expected
to like Mansfield Park
better and, having finished
the first volume,
flattered herself
she had got through the worst."
[LAUGHTER]
Between 1814 and 1815,
Austen drafted Emma,
perhaps her single
greatest masterpiece,
written at the
height of her powers
and again from the security
of settled life in Chawton.
A superficial acquaintance
with Austen's canon
detects the sameness of
the courtship-driven plot.
But even a cursory
reading of Emma
next to its predecessor,
Mansfield Park,
or its successor, Persuasion,
reveals the exuberance
with which Austen
relished a new challenge.
Emma is everything
Fanny Price is not.
As you can see here, she's
more often in motion.
She's born to wealth and power.
She's talkative and extroverted.
She's admired by many,
including herself.
Like Elizabeth Bennet, she's
a confident young woman who
must confront her own errors.
But Emma's education
unfolds in a series
of revelations that are
drawn out through a highly
intricate plot.
And she's also distinct
in that, through
the masterful manipulation
of point of view,
her overconfidence is
exposed to us from the start.
This is what generates the
delightful humor of her story.
If Elizabeth is written
something like a friend
to the reader, Emma is a beloved
niece, one whose progress
we chart with bemused affection
from a stance of greater
experience.
If we look on Emma's
progress from the vantage
point of more mature
knowledge, Austen herself
was growing into the
role of loving advisor
to her nephews and nieces.
She cautioned her
niece Fanny not
to be overly charmed by
charisma or wit in a suitor
but to study private character.
She encouraged her niece
Anna, an aspiring writer,
to value precision over
flair and to be content
with a narrow focus, to find
the drama in a modest setting,
and to avoid phrases like
vortex of dissipation.
By early 1816, when
Emma was published,
Austen was herself
composing a drama
in which modesty and patience
are the central virtues.
In its opening chapters, Austen
describes the chastened mindset
of her aging heroine.
Anne Elliott is 27 and verging
on confirmed spinsterhood.
"She had been forced into
prudence in her youth.
She learned romance as she
grew older, the natural sequel
to an unnatural beginning."
In her personal
copy of the novel,
Cassandra wrote in the
margin, "Dear, dear Jane, this
deserves to be written
in letters of gold,"
as if these words hold a special
key to Jane Austen's mind
and heart.
And I think the notion of
learning romance is the reason.
The belief that
happy endings emerge
from the quality of attention
we bestow on outwardly
undramatic people as well
as commonplace moments
and settings is an insight
that explains the lasting power
and lasting relevance
of Austen's fiction.
Originally titled The Elliotts
and published as Persuasion,
this last finished
work is shorter
than Austen's earlier
novels and, in some ways,
more muted in tone.
She was beginning
to feel unwell.
She had the disposable
income to buy back
the manuscript for
Northanger Abbey
from Crosby's publishing
house, but she
made only minimal
revisions and set
it aside, perhaps a sign
of her diminished energy.
In May, she visited a
spa for refreshment--
May of 1816, that is, and later
that summer, entertaining house
guests while Cassandra
was away, expressed
with a sense of wistfulness
that, "composition
seems to me impossible with a
head full of joints of mutton
and doses of rhubarb."
She must have been thinking
of Sanditon, a story set in
and up-and-coming
resort town that
appears to be, among
other things, a satire
on those who frequent spas and
suffer from imaginary illness.
"Sickness is a dangerous
indulgence at my time of life,"
she wrote with a chin-up
attitude to her niece Fanny.
Nevertheless, she was too unwell
to draft more than 12 chapters
of Sanditon.
Austen's niece Caroline later
described a touching scene
from around this time.
"Aunt Jane used often to
lie down after dinner.
My grandmother herself was
frequently on the sofa,
sometimes in the afternoon,
sometimes in the evening,
at no fixed period of the day.
She had not bad
health for her age,
and she worked often
for hours in the garden
and, naturally, wanted
rest afterwards.
There was only one
sofa in the room.
And Aunt Jane laid
upon three chairs,
which she arranged for herself.
I think she had a pillow, but
it never looked comfortable.
She called it her sofa.
And even when the other was
unoccupied, she never took it.
I often asked her how she
could like the chairs best.
And I suppose I worried
her into telling me
the reason of her choice,
which was that if she ever
used the sofa, Grandmama
would be leaving it for her
and would not lie
down, as she did now,
whenever she felt inclined."
I can never decide
if this reflects
an excess of good manners
or a sense of distance
between mother and
daughter, or perhaps those
are two sides of a single coin.
As it happened, as
spring advanced,
Jane's letters confess
that she is increasingly
confined to bed.
She suffers fevers, back
pain, and a growing fatigue.
After periods of
seeming convalescence,
she would experience
bouts of pain that
belied the notion of progress.
What was her illness?
For many years, the suggestion
was Addison's disease,
which is a tuberculosis
of the adrenal glands.
But a more recent
hypothesis points
to some form of lymphoma.
We'll never be sure.
The letters from March and April
of 1817 brim with gratitude
for the devoted
care of her family
and the buoyant
expectation of improvement.
It's interesting to wonder
if, in this attitude,
Austen was consciously crafting
a fiction for her first
and last audience, her
family circle, for in April,
unbeknownst even
to Cassandra, she
drew up an unwitnessed will.
A month later, the sisters
took lodgings in Winchester
to consult an experienced
physician there.
By June, Jane was apparently too
weak to take up her pen at all.
But words were her
connection with life.
On July 15, she
dictated to Cassandra
a poem of 24 lines
on the subject
of the annual
Winchester horse races.
Remarkable how she continued
to turn her attention
outward to the life around her.
And early on the morning of
July 18, she died with her head
in Cassandra's lap.
Her last surviving
letter to a nephew
concludes with a
poignant reflection
of what this keen
observer saw and felt when
she turned her eyes on herself.
"God bless you, my dear Edward.
If ever you are ill,
may you be as tenderly
nursed as I have been.
May the same blessed
alleviations of anxious,
sympathizing friends be yours.
And may you possess,
as I daresay you will,
the greatest blessing of all in
the consciousness of not being
unworthy of their love.
I could not feel this.
Your very affectionate
aunt, JA."
She was buried in
Winchester Cathedral,
the place marked with
a black marble plaque
and an inscription that cites
the extraordinary endowments
of her mind as just
one of many virtues.
With Cassandra's
help, Henry composed
a brief biographical
notice for their sister
and arranged for
Northanger Abbey
to be published with Persuasion
by the end of the year.
The pairing is odd but also apt.
Persuasion, her last
completed novel, and featuring
a heroine subdued by
painful experience,
alongside Northanger
Abbey, scarcely
touched since Austen
had drafted it
20 years earlier with her most
naive heroine and certainly
her most ebullient narrator.
The comparison shows us
that Austen never wrote
half-heartedly, never wrote with
less than mastery of her craft,
and never stopped
changing and growing.
50 years later, the nephew
to whom Austen addressed
her last letter, James
Edward Austen Lee,
would compose a more
detailed memoir,
which seems to have catalyzed
interest in her work.
Both sales and
critical commentary
were modest before the
turn of the century.
Her popularity with
ordinary readers,
as opposed to fellow
novelists, was
boosted by the emergence
of paperback editions
in the mid-20th century.
And since then, she
has proved herself
worthy of a very rare
honor, an assured
place in the canon of
great books in the academy
and the lasting
devotion of those
who read only for pleasure.
In the words of Northanger
Abbey, "And what
are you reading, miss?
Oh, it is only a novel,
replies the young lady,
while she lays down her book
with affected indifference
or momentary shame.
It is only Cecilia, or Camilla,
or Belinda, or, in short,
only some work in which the
greatest powers of the mind
are displayed, in which
the most thorough knowledge
of human nature, the happiest
delineation of its varieties,
the liveliest effusions
of wit and humor
are conveyed to the world in
the best chosen language."
Given her current fame,
another adaptation
of Sense and Sensibility
or Emma might
seem ordinary, nothing special.
What are your plans this
evening, you might be asked.
Oh, I'm only attending
the Jane Austen CCA.
I'm confident, however,
that those of us
who take a closer
look will continue
to prize a quiet exuberance that
belongs to only Jane Austen.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you, Dr. Murphy.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way to one of
the microphones in the aisle.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Dr. Murphy.
I was just curious
if we have access
to the original draft
of Elinor and Marianne,
and if we see any significant
differences between that draft
and Sense and Sensibility,
which was written
after all of her heartache.
LORRAINE MURPHY: We do not have
access to that first draft.
And I believe it's on the basis
mainly of internal evidence
in the finished Sense
and Sensibility,
although I think also from
one or two brief remarks
in her letters
that we are pretty
confident it was originally
in the epistolary style
and then revised.
But we do not have that draft.
Of her published
novels, her finished
novels, the only
manuscript that survives
is interestingly, the concluding
two chapters of Persuasion,
which she canceled and rewrote.
So what we have is
what she threw out.
And it's quite
interesting to see
what she wrote the first time.
But of her finished work, that's
the only manuscript in her hand
that survives.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So in recent years, some
criticisms of the economist
Adam Smith have been that when
he wrote Wealth of Nations,
he had this maidservant who was
literally taking care of him
the entire time.
So of course he's going to write
this incredible economic theory
about capitalism because, well,
he doesn't have to do anything.
At least reflecting on the
quote, like "a mind lively
and at ease can do
with seeing nothing,"
could you see future
literary criticisms
of Jane Austen appearing
basically because, as you said,
when she was at the
peak of her powers,
she was allowed to
write the entire day,
and it didn't really
seem to be that there
is much of a struggle or
intersectional narrative
being applied towards
her life at that time.
LORRAINE MURPHY: If I
understand your question,
it's concerning future novelists
or concerning Austen herself?
AUDIENCE: So concerning
Austen herself,
could you see people criticizing
her currently or in the future
because when she
was writing, that
was kind of all she had to do?
Of course, she's going to
produce all these works.
But was there any real
struggle involved at that time?
LORRAINE MURPHY: You see
that critique of her work
sometimes, of her fiction,
where you have a way of life.
Mrs. Bennet boasts
her daughters have
nothing to do in the kitchen,
that that's all taken care of.
When Austen and her
sister and mother
lived at Chawton
Cottage, they did
have some help in the
kitchen, but that did not
mean that they were uninvolved.
But I mean, Jane Austen
grew up in a family
where she was accustomed
to working and making
a contribution.
Everyone with an
able pair of hands
was accustomed to working
and making a contribution.
And she and her
sister and mother
worked something out
where they agreed
to shoulder a
burden with a loving
sense of Jane's vocation.
So she certainly was not
distant from the reality
of labor and the way
that labor supports
leisure and creativity.
In her will, she left
everything to Cassandra
except 50 pounds to her brother
Henry, whose bank had failed,
and 50 pounds to a servant of
a sister-in-law, for whom she
had a friendship.
She maintained an ongoing
correspondence, a very friendly
correspondence
with the woman who
was the governess at her
brother Edward's home in Kent.
So she seems to have had a great
sympathy for working women,
and I think she was
closer to that reality
than we realize if we only
read her published work.
AUDIENCE: I know
you said that there
weren't any satisfactory
versions of Mansfield
Park on film.
I'm curious.
Why do you think that is?
Is there something about it
that's difficult to adapt?
LORRAINE MURPHY: I think so.
One thing about Austen
that is very easy to adapt
is her dialogue.
She writes wonderful dialogue.
And she has a wonderful
ear for voice,
and for those little inflections
of mannerisms of speech
that gives such a lively
sense of character.
So in a lot of film
adaptations, you'll
find the dialogue
almost word for word
what you'll find in the novels.
But as I said, Fanny
Price almost never speaks.
And it's difficult,
I think, on film--
not impossible,
certainly, but I think
it's difficult to give a
sense of the drama going
on in the mind with
so little being said.
And in some ways, the
liveliest adaptation
of Mansfield Park that I've seen
makes Fanny Price an entirely
different character.
And the moviemakers
seem to have decided
to replace Fanny Price with
a picture of the young Jane
Austen, which is interesting,
but it's not Fanny Price.
So her silence and her
passivity, her weakness--
even when she's
pushed or pressed,
she often doesn't
wish to respond.
And even for readers
of the novel,
that can feel frustrating.
So translating that to film is
maybe especially frustrating.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LORRAINE MURPHY: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for your talk.
I was just wondering, how common
was it at that time for women
to be authors?
And what kind of
obstacles did that
present Austen in her career?
LORRAINE MURPHY: It was--
I don't know if you'd call
it common but common enough
that Austen was familiar with
the published work, certainly
of other female novelists.
The obstacle was leisure.
So even if Austen had, let's
say, married Harris Bigg-Wither
and become quite a wealthy
woman living a comfortable life,
her duties as the
head of the household
would probably
have prevented her
from having that time to sit
down and draft and revise.
Women often didn't publish
under their own names.
So none of Austen's work was
published in her lifetime
under her name.
But that didn't mean
that women weren't
interested in professional
success and the independence
that that could provide.
So there were models,
but they were not many.
And as you could see, Austen had
to sort of forge a way of life
that would support her work.
And that was sometimes
difficult to do.
AUDIENCE: In
previous lectures, it
had been said that when
she was writing her novels,
she took for granted
her social class
and that the novels weren't
necessarily to depict that.
Would you say that that is an
accurate description of how
she wrote in regards
to social class,
especially considering
the fact that, at least it
seems like in her
younger years and then
after her father's death,
her social status wasn't
necessarily secure?
LORRAINE MURPHY: I think that
she took the class system,
if we want to call
it that, for granted,
as has been said
a couple of times.
And I don't think she was
setting out to reform it
or to question it in
any kind of radical way.
And I think sometimes,
it's easy to overlook.
She wrote about a
social way of life
that was a degree or
two above her own.
And it's a way of life she
would have been familiar with,
for example, at her
brother Edward's home
or at Harris Bigg-Withers' home.
She moved in a circle
where this way of life
could be known to her and
could become familiar to her,
but it wasn't her way of life.
And I think that
if she chooses not
to make that a central tension
in her novels, the difference
between what a woman
like Jane Austen
has to do with her duties
and daily responsibilities
versus what a woman like
Elizabeth Bennet has to do.
It's a question that, in
some sense, doesn't come up
or comes up in subtle, quiet
ways that can be probed
but that don't really
cry out for attention.
The one novel where
she does take,
I think, a closer and
maybe more critical
look at England's social system
is her last work, Persuasion.
And it's interesting
to wonder what
she might have done in Sanditon,
but we can't be too sure.
But in Persuasion,
you have a kind
of dialogue between
the landed gentry,
as exemplified by Sir
Walter Elliot, who
is a really comical but
sad failure of a baronet,
and the navy.
And Austen loved the navy, and
was very loyal to the navy,
and very proud of her brothers
who were naval officers.
And there you have a sort
of merit-based social system
that, in Persuasion,
Austen seems
to find very refreshing
and positive.
So I wouldn't say
that social critique
is absent from her work.
But it's muted.
And I certainly
think that she's not
a thoroughgoing
radical egalitarian.
She knows that roles can
be, while limiting, also
very supportive of the
relationships that we establish
and the work that we do,
if you like, in society.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned that Pride
and Prejudice was originally
titled First Impressions.
So I was wondering if you
could speak a little bit more
on that.
Why was the reason for
the change in title?
And who did this?
And then why Pride and Prejudice
versus First Impressions?
LORRAINE MURPHY: I'm
not 100% sure on this,
but I think that her
publisher suggested
the title Pride and Prejudice.
And I think that was
based on the style.
It was doing well at the time.
Austen herself does
not seem to have
been a great writer of titles.
And her siblings changed
the titles she had in mind
as she drafted
things with titles.
She just used the name.
The Elliots, Susan, and Emma.
[LAUGHTER]
Why First Impressions?
I think because both
Darcy and Elizabeth
Bennet are too reliant on
their first impressions.
And Austen was always very
interested in a society--
and this builds a little
bit on the last question--
where mannered behavior
was very important,
and there was a kind of
decorum and structure
to what you could say
and do in society.
It can be difficult to
read between the lines.
You have to make a judgment
based on what people say and do
in society.
And often, two
people who are going
to be engaged to be
married would never
have been alone together.
They would have seen
each other entirely
in social and socially
controlled settings.
So the importance of looking
past first impressions
is, I think, what she's really
driving at in that novel.
SPEAKER: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for your
time tonight, Dr. Murphy.
So from your
discussion, it seems
that Austen had a really
special relationship
with several members of her
family, especially her sister.
And just considering that
there are several sister pairs
and close female friendships
in her books, can you just
talked a little bit about
how her relationship
with her sister might have
impacted those relationships
in the books.
LORRAINE MURPHY: They
were very, very close.
As I said, when Cassandra
was away, Jane had to write.
She had to put down her
thoughts to Cassandra.
You can see that in
the comment her mother
made when they were girls,
Jane's devotion to Cassandra.
I think the fact
that they had both
known the sadness of perhaps
anticipating marriage--
certainly, Cassandra had
anticipated a marriage.
And Jane, I think, had
at least begun to do so.
And letting go of that must
have bound them closer together.
And by the time Jane died,
they would have anticipated
growing old together.
And this was-- as I say,
it's a social world where
the behavior at a card party, or
in a sitting room, or at a meal
has a kind of script to it.
And the number of
people with whom
you would share your
unvarnished, from the heart
emotions and feelings and
words would be very few.
And Cassandra was, I think,
that person for Jane,
and I'm sure Jane was
that person for Cassandra.
And sibling
relationships in general
are prized in her novels.
Again, we tend to think of them
as the novels about courtship
and marriage, but they're
really novels about societies
and communities.
And siblings are
our first society.
Jane loved that.
SPEAKER: Please join me
in thanking Dr. Murphy.
[APPLAUSE]